Democrats are panicked that they peaked
too early with three weeks to go before
the midterms but hey Like Jesse in high
school it happens to the best of us the
party of woke scolds and gender studies
grads now realizing that the momentum
they had over the summer is melting away
faster than Joe Biden's ice cream one
Lefty mourning the impending doom saying
quote I'm wishing the election were in
August sorry Jack they're still in
November the reason why Democrats are
throwing a pity party now is because of
a batch of polls that has Republicans
pulling away including a brutal New York
Times one that shows Independent Women
swingly swingly swinging certainly
toward Republicans in the span of a
month but Nancy Pelosi is still in total
denial
let's talk about Rising inflation
concerns along with crime giving
momentum new momentum to Republicans
after the Democrats were closing the Gap
I think that much of what you've said I
don't agree with that is to say the New
York Times poll I think is an outlier
poll what we had been through with the
legislation under the leadership of
President Biden who has done a
spectacular job he's had a better two
years than most uh presidents that you
can name certainly in the recent
Generations yeah goodbye and Joy Behar
failing to live up to her name again the
view co-host is upset that voters are
more focused on pocketbook issues
but what's depressing is that the New
York Times released a poll today that
says that 71 percent of Voters agree
that democracy is under threat yeah
percent of Voters uh rank a threat to
democracy as a major issue this election
cycle yeah I find that so depressing I
can't begin to tell you I don't like
polls I don't like balls Dana that tells
you everything
about January 6th they did but the thing
is that she was like she says it's so
depressing that people are I think that
democracy is in Peril but they the
Democrats were the ones funding the very
candidates now that they're worried
about getting elected right so
congratulations you know your mission
accomplished throwback to yesterday
um one of the things about them at the
Democrats is they just spent all their
money way too early on an issue that was
going to go away so it's like imagine I
did this beautiful etching sketch and
then Greg comes along and knocks it out
of my hands and shakes it all up and
it's gone you're like well wait I just
wasted 100 million dollars on something
that um I'm not going to be able to run
on today the Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer says we're going to do
this uh mag we're going to go after Mega
Republicans by having to build a codify
Roe v Wade which is kind of weird
because the Supreme Court just said
there's no uh constitutional right to an
abortion but go ahead pass the bill and
have the Supreme Court knock it down
again fine but that tells me that
they've just spent hundreds of millions
of dollars on abortion ads but they're
not willing to say where they are on on
abortion these last three weeks of the
debates have been more about the
Democrats having to defend their
position about abortion all the way up
till birth rather than on the limited
version that most Americans want so
they're in a little bit of a pickle yep
going all in on abortion all right peers
President Biden had been lecturing you
Brits about the economy so now it's your
chance to respond well first of all
thank you for having me back I don't
know if any of you actually knew I was
coming back or even if you agree to me
happy but but I'm grateful to be here um
yes what do they feel about President
Biden munching his massive ice cream
which Jesse I have to say hat tip to you
your denunciation of the ice cream
eating no man should ever be seen eating
a gigantic cone the only thing I would
have added to your brilliant brilliant
assessment of how inappropriate it was
is that it was also inappropriate
because actually what he was doing with
that Conan his hand was revealing the
wider truth about the economy Ice Cream
prices are up about 13 because Dairy
farming costs have gone through the roof
why have they gone through the roof why
is milk so expensive because of
inflation items can keep saying there's
zero inflation there's 8.2 percent
inflation that is now Rippling through
everybody's lives and making every
everything very expensive so I can see a
president when he says the U.S economy
is strong as hell it starts lecturing
the British prime minister who by the
way he's right about one thing she is
utterly useless and in fact even by the
time we come off air she may no longer
be British prime minister so on on the
factual side he's correct but he is the
I made the point in my New York Post
column yesterday it would be like Kim
Kardashian lecturing people on being
talentless waste trolls she might be
right but she's not the right person to
deliver that message and I thought that
about Badness like come on look at your
own backyard before you lecture the rest
of the world about the economy and he
seems to me to be suffering from what I
call acute delusion it's like me looking
at here seeing the clear blue lovely
skyer this beautiful sunny day in New
York City and saying it's pouring with
rain and Pitch Black you would all look
at me and go no it's knob is it's blue I
would say no it's not it's raining and
it's pitch black and you'd say the man's
completely nuts he's lost his marbles
that's where I am with I'm afraid yeah
the leader of the Free World he is
saying things which simply aren't true
and so when it comes to the midterms I
think my prediction the American people
who know it's untrue because they're
paying the extra costs every day they
are going to vote accordingly yes that's
the thing Church we're still people are
seeing his his acts the consequences of
his presidency what peer says is exactly
right the American people know that it's
untrue so if you think about what they
tell us that we can't verify or confirm
I mean it's not all of a sudden that
this is the first time they're lying to
us from Washington but I really want to
talk about the abortion issue for just a
second because I think it's so so
important first of all people think that
women vote on one issue only and they
don't and it's about time that they
recognize women as more than just women
who are concerned about people concerned
about abortion okay they were so
invested in this issue after the
official decision was leaked by the
Supreme Court that they allowed for the
disruption for months for six weeks at
least seven weeks after the decision
came out of people going in front of the
Justice's home they attempted
assassination on Justice Kavanaugh and
all of the outrage that's how they were
playing it out so it wasn't just the ads
and of course they spent Millions you're
right Dana ahead of time on these ads on
abortion but they made the world America
at least look at all this lunacy that no
one was buying into because the people
who were watching it were had to go to
the store and figure out how much money
they had for dinner for the week for
their kids and how far they could drive
so you know what they may have peaked
too early and I think it's it's it's not
just that they Peak too early I think
that the Republicans are seeing and have
a Hands-On what's going on we should
feel sorry by the way because peaking
too early is a medical condition yes it
is I actually do understand my sympathy
to all Democrats yes who speak to us I
believe we have a number of those
commercials that one during this show
you see a guy in a classic car jogging
on the beach you Jesse my theory is that
nobody bought the garbage about the
inflation reduction act because when you
looked at the red inflation reduction
act there was no inflation reduction
right so we could no longer trust
anything that they had to say first I
take issue with your intro I peaked in
Middle School not high school here's
what happened the Democrats are saying
they peaked in August what was everybody
doing in August we were on vacation we
were drunk we were tan we weren't
watching television we weren't paying
attention to what Democrats in DC were
doing we were with our families and we
were enjoying life I was actually in a
Maximum Security Prison interviewing
serial killers yeah and I'll just say
that in there I was here at the table
that's a vacation I was doing charity
work
they got lucky when they caught a trend
they had nothing to do with because
remember the market rallied in August
off the summer lows and gas prices came
down off the summer highs they had
nothing to do with either of those
things once people get back in session
in September demand is up for gasoline
they're going back to work and they're
watching TV and paying attention and gas
prices go up and mortgage rates
Skyrocket and people start focusing on
the failures of the Democrats and that's
when things got bad
the elites have never paid any attention
to inflation and who's the guy that the
chief of staff Ron Clane he gave it away
early last year when he said inflation
is a high class problem they've never
understood how middle class and lower
class workers have to deal with high
prices they've been completely detached
this entire time and they're going to
pay for it
I actually and I don't like Nancy Pelosi
I'm with Nancy on this you have to just
continue to claim you're going to win
this thing right like the guy that
leaked this thing the Politico that says
it's not looking too good for Democrats
we peaked early he should be brought
outside in shot because that's off
message you have to stay on message but
remember Donald Trump was like it's
actually going to be a red wave like you
got to go in just to keep the troops
motivated so I understand what she's
saying and Pierce you and I don't agree
on much especially with weapons but a
man should never lick an ice cream cone
in public never never never it's like
talking about Christmas before December
the 1st
should be a criminal effect it's
sacrilegious lock them up that's what I
say by the way you know what a real high
class problem is is the wokism you're
right that's that's the high class
problem right that's what Obama said
yesterday I went on Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all all here
on YouTube so subscribe right now